i was
considering
actual coming-of-age rituals
uh like rome springer
of the amish
which is uh for those who never heard of
it uh it's it's called the running
around period
um when amish youth of both sexes at 16
or 17
are
allowed
to be freed for some amount of time from
the restrictions uh and many of the
perks of the amish community and church
and then at the end of some period they
must they must choose they must choose
to either
come back into the fold
with all of the
positives and negatives that accompany
that or to reject
their
life here too far
up until then
completely and to go out into the world
and and not be amish so am i am i
correct that um you said it a little a
little too carefully i think okay they
are allowed to participate as a modern
person well i yeah i said it very
carefully because though i didn't spend
a lot of time and mostly the books i'm
i don't have access to a good library
anymore one of one of the few perks of
modern college affiliation is an
excellent library so um there
i
i dug as much as i could in the little
bit of time that i spent at it and it
seems
that the for those who have heard of it
mostly what we have in our heads is kind
of a time of um you know almost like
spring break right it's like it's like
college kids on spring break all the
restrictions are off and they're going
to be at their worst right i think um
brum springer often actually has some um
adult amish still in like still
overseeing there's still some ac there's
still a lot of organized activities um i
i suspect that there's some of that but
it does seem like it's actually a much
more
um staid and less sort of orgyastic
experience
i would never have imagined that a
person raised amish liberated to do what
they want would go spring break i mean
you know i think frankly most kids avoid
that well it's possible that there was
just a reality tv show
about this that got into people's heads
because that seems to be the thing that
is in people's heads about it well my
guess would be
if you've been properly raised and if
there's one thing that an amish
community is likely to do it's to
properly raise its children yeah um then
you liberate them and they're going to
be skeptical of an awful lot of what the
modern world has to offer i wouldn't
mind but also quite curious sure yeah of
course of course but anyway the basic
point is they are liberated to some
extent maybe fully what that means they
actually do is an open question and then
i think it's a year they it varies it
varies they come back and they have to
decide whether they want to continue
effectively in the modern world or they
want to return to their yeah so i guess
that that version is much tidier than
the actual reality is part of why i was
being very careful because i had i had a
couple of things in my head sort of that
that version and then the like the
spring break version and neither of them
are true it seems yeah um
but
you know probably to some degree there's
as much variation as there are people
who engage in this uh one thing that i
think holds from what we have understood
uh in the past is that um the vast
majority like you know almost to a
person
come back into the fold come back
to to be amish again but anyway that got
me thinking about uh this video that i
saw back in october of 2021
uh in which a
uh
well actually why don't we just why
don't we zack if you would play the
first uh almost two and a half minutes
of this
uh it's a it's a news report on a
channel that hopefully will be obvious
when it comes to actions taken to
address the covet 19 threat hindsight is
still very much underway
for your consideration a story and
outcome you probably aren't hearing much
about anywhere else it takes place in
the heart of amish country
lancaster county pennsylvania thousands
of families lead lives largely separate
from modern america
the amish are a christian group that
emphasizes the virtuous over the
superficial they don't usually drive use
electricity or have tvs
and during the covet 19 outbreak they
became subjects in a massive social and
medical experiment
so it's safe to say there was a whole
different approach here in this
community when coronavirus broke out
than many other places absolutely
calvin lapp is amish mennonite there's
three things the amish don't like
and that's government they won't get
involved in government they don't like
the public education system they won't
send their children to education and
they they also don't like the health
system
they
they rip us off those are three things
that we
feel like we're fighting against all the
time well those three things are all
part of what kovit is
after a short shutdown last year the
amish chose a unique path that led to
covid19 tearing through at warp speed it
began with an important religious
holiday in may
when they take communion they they dump
their wine into a cup
and they take turns to drink out of that
cup so you go the whole way down the
line
and everybody drinks out of that cup
so if one person has a friend of ours
the rest of church is going to get
credit of ours first time they went back
to church
everybody got corner of ours
lapp says they weren't denying
coronavirus they were facing it head on
it's the worst thing to
quit working than dying
but to shut down and say that we can't
go to church we can't get together with
family we can't see our old people in
the hospital we got to quit working
you're working it's going completely
against everything that we believe
and you you're changing our culture
completely to try to act like they
wanted us to act the last year
and we're not going to do it
so he says
there's three things that the amish
won't get involved with government
education and healthcare and those three
things are all central in the coveted
response
remarkable remarkable and there is a
so i don't know if you'll remember this
but when we first started discussing
writing
uh the hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century
i wanted chapter one
to be
titled are the amish right
that of course got long since abandoned
as we developed our idea of what should
be in there but i think the question is
an important one because the amish of
course
seem
strange to us it's like the very
definition of anachronism to be driving
your horse in you know 2022 on asphalt
on asphalt right um on the other hand
given the theme of the book which is
hyper novelty or at least that's one of
the central themes of the book is hyper
novelty the question is well all right
you have these people who
bailed out of technology or bailed out
of the advance of technology
and the question really is and in that
level
were they right that the trouble is not
worth it and
um
in any case later in this in this video
um
he says
no the the narrator says the journalist
says
one thing is clear there is no evidence
of any more deaths among the amish than
in places that shut down tight some
claim that some claim there were fewer
here that's without masking staying at
home or much vaccination
right which raises all kinds of
interesting questions because the amish
are not in a great position to perfectly
protect themselves to the extent right
and as we as we hear here they get you
know they they believe and you know many
people have had this experience and you
know what why are we distrusting
mistrusting maltrusting i don't even
know what the word is anymore um
uh people who say okay someone had
coveted and they did the sharing the
i we can't hear it when you watch it so
i don't remember if it was wine or what
if they're
they're sharing the thing and then
everyone got sick right and then they
ended up um all better
and but what i mean is they can't
protect themselves from the folly of the
modern world in the sense that if yeah
vaccination drove the evolution of
variance they're exposed to variance too
so to make sense that what this story is
about is about herd immunity
they are not in a position to prevent
the thing from evolving away because of
what modern folks are doing to it rather
than what they did
nonetheless in spite of that um
the
benefit of doing
it's not even exactly nothing but the
benefit of not imagining that you were
going to outwit technologically this
virus
may well have been superior in the
aggregate and this is one of the things
i really i don't know that we will ever
get an honest accounting of it yeah but
i think it's very important that at some
point we get an honest accounting of the
difference between i think it would be
three categories one is what we did
right what were the consequences of that
for human health well-being and
longevity
there's a question and also things like
happiness
correlated damage
second thing would be
if one did nothing
right
and the third thing would be if someone
if we had approached it organically
rather than the top down
the cdc is gospel
view of what we should have done if
doctors were allowed to do what doctors
are supposed to do which is be
scientists and
try out things based on the symptoms
they see in front of them and discover
what works and compare notes and you
know prescribe as they will
[Music]
you